-That's a movie star!
That's a stud right there.
Welcome.
It is great to see you.
Thank you for being here
in person. I appreciate that.
-Well, it's very nice to be here
in person. Thank you.
-How are the family?
How are the kids?
-They're good.
-Yeah.
-Their thing at the moment
is just screaming.
-Ah, that sounds peaceful.
[ Laughter ]
-They're, like, really good
at it, you know.
But it's all -- you know, like,
our 8-year-old,
I feel like she is going through
some kind of --
Apparently, we've since found
out that around eight,
they get some hormonal surge.
And she's just, like, guttural
screaming a lot,
which encourages the 2-year-old,
who is doing that anyway
in her own kind of way.
And then the 5-year-old sits
in the middle just like going,
"I may as well join in."
-Yeah.
And you're just driving going,
"This is awesome."
-But occasionally, we take
a break to listen to
the soundtrack for "Encanto."
That's our -- Yeah.
-I mean, that's what everyone's
doing right now.
-That's what everyone's doing.
-That represents everyone.
It's screaming and "Encanto"
right now.
-How good is the music?
-We don't talk about Bruno.
Yeah, I mean, come on.
-We might talk about Bruno.
-Exactly. Yeah, yeah.
-We're allowed to talk about
Bruno.
-Speaking of singing,
by the way,
I saw a really cool thing.
You were singing
"Rainbow Connection."
-I was.
-In the Kermit the Frog voice.
I have it here.
Can we just show it?
-♪ Why are there so many songs
about rainbows? ♪
♪ What's on the other side? ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Nailed it! Nailed it!
-Yeah.
-It looks like you might be
singing to your girls there.
-I'm not. That's sad, I'm not.
[ Laughter ]
-You're not?
-I'm just singing to my groomer
before I go on
another talk show.
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
-There were no kids in the room?
-No.
I'm not even sure my kids have
seen that.
[ Laughter ]
I was mucking around with a
guitar and I was just --
I've always loved that song, you
know, so I was singing that song
anyway and then realized that
I could sing it like Kermit.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that you could do
something like that
but then you could also do
"Belfast."
I mean, you're kind of
doing everything.
-That's the idea, isn't it?
-Yeah, I guess that's the fun of
acting, yeah.
Congrats.
It's getting great reviews.
It's been nominated for
every award I can think of.
You're getting Oscar buzz.
That must be exciting.
I mean, I know it's --
You're going around
and you're on all of the lists
and everything like that,
but for anyone who hasn't seen
"Belfast," can you set it up?
What it's about?
-Yeah.
Yeah, so it's --
our writer/director
Sir Kenneth Branagh --
-Kenneth Branagh. Awesome.
-Who's just a legend.
-Yeah.
-It's sort of
semi-autobiographical
about his childhood growing up
in Belfast.
A lot of people don't realize he
has any connection to Ireland.
But he was brought up
in Belfast.
We go from 1969
when he was nine years old
and follow the beginning of
the conflict,
which would go on for 30 years,
we know, and its troubles,
and it's a sort of 9-year-old
boy's account of his family
and how they were dealing with
that situation at that time.
-Now, were born and raised
in Belfast?
-Yep.
-And I read that you were
the only actor that Kenneth
considered for the role.
That's got to feel good.
-He's lost his mind.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I mean, that's -- Have you ever
met Kenneth Branagh before
or come close to working
with him?
-I did audition for "Thor"
when he directed "Thor"
way back when.
But I didn't -- you know, I'd --
I've talked to Ken about --
I don't even think he saw
my tape, it was that bad.
[ Laughter ]
-To play Thor?
-No, no -- like, no.
I don't know, one of the guys.
-One of his buddies.
-Yeah, one of his, you know --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Smaller buddies, I think.
[ Laughter ]
But Ken -- I grew up with
a picture of Kenneth Branagh
on our bookshelf
of him and my dad.
My dad was a professor of
medicine,
and he opened a maternity ward
at the hospital
my dad spent the majority
of his career at.
So there's a picture of my dad
with Kenneth Branagh
and a couple of other doctors
always in my house.
-Really?
-Yeah, it was cool.
Sort of full circle.
-I loved it.
Obviously, I'm Irish -- Fallon.
-Yep.
-But I loved it because it was
a different type of Irish movie
that you would see out there
and, like --
you kind of go like -- I loved
it, I appreciated it.
But it's really just a family is
what it was really about.
-Yeah, and I think that's why
it's resonated so well.
You know, we're making a movie
about a tiny place
on a tiny island that people
don't really know
that much about really,
even though we've spread
ourselves pretty far, the Irish.
But, you know, we -- it is at
a particular point in time,
but it is essentially,
as you said,
it's about a family and it's
about family dealing with crisis
and we can all -- every single
person here can understand that.
-Yeah. Does it -- There's a part
of the movie towards the middle,
towards the end, but you end up
just singing --
♪ Everlasting love ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
It's such a great song,
But it's at the perfect part of
the movie because it's been
such a tough thing to watch.
And that scene to me was
my scene because
I loved it because I saw you
guys were just in love.
-Yeah, listen,
it's been a lovely --
The response to that scene
has been incredible.
And for us, it's a moment of
escapism and a release that you
kind of need at that point
in the film.
But also, like, it's essentially
about through the medium of song
these two central characters, my
character saying to his wife,
"Look, we are going through
the wringer here.
This is tough but I've got you.
Don't worry. I've got you.
I love you.
It's going to be okay
and that's not changing."
-That's what I'm talking
about it, yeah.
Is it nerve-wracking to just
sing and just dance and --
-Yeah, I've been doing it
too much recently.
-Kermit the Frog, yeah.
-I mean, that's a choice,
a bad choice, but, you know.
The last few things
I've ended up singing.
But I think I know what
I'm doing next
and I know I don't sing in it so
we are all going to be spared.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I want to talk more
about the movie
and show a clip
when we come back.
More with Jamie Dornan
after the break. Come on back.